ما زال اسم رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا جاستندا
ايضا اللي اعلنت بشكل مفاجئ ان ما عاد
عندها طاقه التي ترشح من جديد وتكمل اربع
سنوات كمان
في السماء
هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ميسي ميسي
[تصفيق]
وطبعا من وقت ما اعلن الجسم عن استقالتها
والتحليلات عن سبب الاستقاله المفاجاه ما
توقفت طبعا واللي من بنى تفسيرات نروح
بتقول انا ما عندي طاقه خلاص يعني اكيد
بتعاني من الاحتراق الوظيفه وهو حاله من
الارهاق والتعب الجسدي والعاطفي اللي يمكن
ان يحدث بعد التعرض لضغط طويل الامد في
الوظيفه وتم الاعتراف باعتبار حاله طبيه
في عام 2019 من قبل منظمه الصحه العالميه
خلينا نعرف اكثر عن همم هذه الحاله وهذا
الموقف يعني اللي صدم كثيرين وتنضم الينا
من القاهره الدكتوره حنان عبد المنعم
خبيره التنميه البشريه اهلا فيك معانا
دكتوره همم حنان همم يعني يمكن موضوع
الاحتراق الوظيفي هذا صار لنا فتره بنتكلم
فيه بس الان رجع للوجه لما ننصدمنا انه
رئيسه وزراء تطلع وتقول انا ما عاد عندي
طاقه اكثر من كده يعني حسيت انصدمتي انت
برده من هذا الموضوع ولا حسيت انه برده
حتى هي مسكينه زي انا موظفه في نهايه
اليوم
مساء الخير عليكم الاول من القاهره
يعني هي كيس الثدي جرس الحقيقه يعني من
ساعه ما طلعت وابتدينا نسمع على انها 37
سنه اصغر رئيس وزراء لبلد زي نيوزيلندا
حاجه طبعا
حقيقي حاجه تشرف جدا على انها امراه وعلى
انها 37 سنه وبعدين فاجاتنا بعد كده
بالسنه اللي فاتت برده في فرحها في يناير
قالت عشان كابتنايتين انا لغيت الفرح
فطبعا دي واحده فاهمه بتعمل ايه وعندها
فيجن وميشن لحياتها قبل اي حاجه ثانيه
بعد كده
الدكتور
حكمها كان فتره حكمها كان فيها صعبه كان
في التفجير الكبير الارهابي اللي واجهته
نيوزيلندا كان في كورونا كان في هذه
الاشياء كلها
ده حقيقي
اه لانها هي قالت حاجه مهمه جدا قالت
حاجتين لازم يدرسوا بالصبر قالت انا بشر
فرحان وقت الرحيل انا بشر سحانه وقت
الرحيل يعني حست انها مش مفروض ان هي هي
حاسه هي ايه وبتدور على كواليتي اوف لايف
بتدور على ان هي الحقيقه مهما
المناصب والكرسي لا انا انا عايزه سلام
نفسي ده نمبر وان نمبر تو الحاجه برده
اللي خلتني فعلا اتوقف عندها انها لما
قالت ان طاقتها استنفذه وانها مش قادره اا
تحقق العداله
اخشى ان نكون طاقتها خلاص كده كفايه انها
ما تحققش العداله الحقيقه اثنين يعني
موقفين ونقطتين مهمين جدا الاولانيه بتقول
لك ان انا بني ادمه زي اي حد في الدنيا
وده طبعا الحقيقه في وطننا العربي لا ده
حاجه مختلفه تماما عن اللي بيحصل ان هي
عندها شجاعه غير عاديه اهي عايزه تكسب
نفسها بس على فكره
كمان دكتوره حنان يعني في ناس قالوا انه
لو كان رجل ما كان تخلى عن مهام الوظيفيه
الحقيقه لا الحقيقه هي دورت عارفه ان هي
المناصب بتحرق البني ادمين والبناصر بتبقى
ليها مسؤوليات شديده جدا وهي فقاره زي اي
حد في الدنيا
اقدر ابص على حاجه ثانيه
يعني هو هذا الشيء ممكن بعض الناس فقط
عن عبد المنعم خبيره التنميه البشريه شكرا
لك